this is how you end a day properly after
traveling for 24 straight hours
you gotta be up in the office - rabbit
rabbit wolf at the corporation talked
about ownership and leveraged a period
sectors that outlet average just blew
took a red-eye after last night's event
in LA connected in Dallas land here in
Naples or Meyers area just a client
pitch looks like we want it which is
exciting
big get remainer big brand exciting I'm
happy about it and and now heading back
to the airport connecting in Chicago and
getting back to LA just a really intense
twenty two hours or so lastly it's
affecting in LA was extraordinary two
thousand people show off for him so much
lemon thank everybody in LA so humbled
you know four hours of photos and self
needs and signings and insert business
questions it's just such an incredible
ego boosters can imagine just a vibe
about vibes booster it's ego booster and
humility at the same time and then and
then just loving kind of mindful living
right now where you know I can have that
kind of moment than Megan rush to the
airport take you for flights in 22 hours
to do a business page one you know just
a person pitching the business loan is
compatible trying to try to get that not
impossible I love shooting for the stars
pitches I am I really want that balance
of equation milites you know rock
stardom
other salesperson time we have and you
know I think that somehow things
[Music]
having the humility to know that you're
not [ __ ] and having the confidence to
know that you're special
for approximately ten Aled ladle on a
plane just landed Chicago now another
plane from Chicago to LA
anyway wanted to describe some my
message media today sometimes I just
kind of something between just kind of
random ideas or thoughts or or have to
put my story that has no context just
little fun for myself
did we all kind of do that want to go
there here is narrow you know over
explore Alfred I mean help you live a
perfect life a man quite nice artistry
top so long talk about more about kind
of water release out how to myself that
I present popular make sure about the
play button or back hair will be
available to try to feel why against two
languages not have on studying more
talkative cell arsenide believe not the
Ebola vitamin or a mark the skin of the
when we service the agency the cleaning
service that we those tools whatever
they come up with the
not XLE is because they actually think
their product is gonna shed and I just
had the proportion of whether it's
baseball cards or vibes that rocket
coming north or books or you know baby
me itself
I just always sold something I believe
in which has allowed me to have passion
be aggressive have conviction and
successful at it so please before you
were even selling figure out if you're
selling to first late app live in LA
driving to the hotel it's quiet in LA
right now long day
really long 24 hours but part of the
process kind of love it that's kind of
like the
snapchat but over Instagram Instagram
story for the door I put up I've got
more conviction than you I think one of
the things that allows me a lot of
people ask me what I don't have my
energy where do I get my energy
[Music]
from and I always talk about gratitude
right lot of you for that answer
wondering how much comes from the fact I
believe so desperately what I'm doing in
the companies that I built in the wind
I'm impacting people and the actions of
like packing culture and communication
platforms is franchising it's my
conviction just so much better than
yours because I just believe so much no
doubt no doubt to my body about my
execution my blueprint my intent and how
this all ends up and so that's what that
little instead post was about
I just appreciate all of you guys go on
this journey that's how you end a day
properly after traveling for 24 straight
hours